[Musique]
je suis une artiste
je suis une idéaliste je suis une
philosophe
je m'intéresse
énormément
aux personnes à leur expérience de la
vie et à leur manière de
on va dire percevoir la vie en général
j'ai récemment conduit une enquête à
laquelle de gens qui personnes ont
accepté de se plier
le point principal de mon enquête
consistait à demander à ces personnes
de formuler une préoccupation actuelle
une préoccupation à laquelle je me
ferais le plaisir de réfléchir et
peut-être de les aider à trouver des
solutions
parmi ces réponses j'ai eu
plus de femmes qui a accepté d'élaborer
un peu leurs préoccupations les hommes
étaient restés un peu plus timide
et ce qui est intéressant
j'ai remarqué que la plupart des sujets
tournés autour
de deux thèmes que je vais vous citer là
comment
reconnaître ce pourquoi en effet comment
clarifier sa vision
comment définir son rêve
comment
joindre emploi et talent ou bien un
emploi et passion
il y à ce commentaire qui venait
également du jeune étudiante apparemment
du son âge puisque l' enquête était
anonyme elle demandait comment prendre
son envol
et sans que les parents
s'en mêlent et essaye de vous retenir
il y avait beaucoup de questions il y en
a une qui a retenu mon attention par sa
simplicité
cette question elle est composée de 2 me
et un point d'interrogation
comment oser
je me suis dit que répondre à cette
question à la lumière de mon expérience
pourrait
aider à répondre à toutes les autres
questions qui ont été posées
voilà ce à quoi je vais m'y atteler à
faire au cours de ces quelques minutes
que nous allons passer ensemble je vais
vous dire comment j'ai osé comment
choses
et essayer de répondre à ces personnes
là qui m'ont posé ces questions et qui
ont demandé que je réfléchisse avec elle
pour moi l'audace n'est pas toujours
quelque chose de brusques surtout quand
il s'agit d'un projet de filles
pour moi on peut oser par étapes
j'ai donc concocté sexe étapes qui sont
adaptables à la plupart des
rêves disons et qui pourrait aider une
personne qui se posent la question
qui se pose la question sur la manière
dosé pour arriver à ce qu'elle voudrait
pour moi la première étape c'est se
cherchent et
se chercher
c'est être à l'écouté de soi
être à l'écouté de son environnement
savoir ce qui nous fait vibrer savoir ce
qu'on fait naturellement savoir sur quoi
on peut avoir accès facilement
savoir ce qui ne nous ennuie pas
se chercher peut prendre deux heures de
temps pour les érudits ou plusieurs
années comme pour moi
tu es ma tendre enfance j'avais à ma
disposition du temps de l'imagination
des crayons
et une amie qui s'intéressait à toutes
ces choses là
je savais donc que
faire carrière ou plutôt cheminer dans
un domaine artistique et créatif était
fait pour moi
des conditions favorables donc sont un
levier intéressant pour se chercher et
se trouvait quand je parle de conditions
favorables je ne dis pas qu'il faut que
tous vous souhaite donner sur un plateau
d'argent même si ce serait mieux
un enfant à qui on a
acheté tous les jouets qu'il veut un
enfant qui a par exemple des jeux de
briques des puzzles
il découvrira peut-être si ça
l'intéresse son amour pour la
construction est peut-être pour la
stratégie
mais à neuf en quête d'un milieu
peut-être plus défavorisés et qui n'a
pas de jouer peut également utiliser
l'absence de jouer comme une opportunité
pour fabriquer des jouets et découvrir
un amour pour la construction c'est
possible
après cette étape
nous nous sommes cherchés disons que ne
sont pas forcément trouvé mais on a des
pistes il y a maintenant l'étape de ces
spirées et demander de l'aide
c'est fear et
consiste à regarder le travail d'autrui
parce que ce que vous voulez faire
existent déjà quelque part dans le monde
même si ce n'est pas à votre manière
aujourd'hui on a internet
aujourd'hui il est facile d'avoir accès
au travail d'une personne d'avoir accès
si vous voulez être journaliste par
exemple à des émissions sur youtube
choisir une personne ou plusieurs
personnes comme modèle comme mentor que
vous pouvez en fait étudier
suivre
également
pour ma part je m'inspirais de cette
manière est aussi en allant voir des
personnes sur place
dans mon environnement parce que c'est
moins facile de rencontrer par exemple
on va dire pour ceux qui connaissent la
mood elie saab que de rencontrer un
styliste béninois ici
j'allais donc
si vous fouillez des magazines je voyais
un nom qui m'intéressait un travail qui
m'intéressait je trouvais le moyen de le
contacter
si je trouvais je regardais une émission
de télé m'est arrivé de regarder une
émission de télé je me rappelle plus de
long et j'ai vu un coiffeur un coiffeur
dont le travail était atypique et qui
accès sont
qui accès en fait comment dire le point
central de son travail sur le confort du
client et c'était parce qu'on voyait
souvent ici je sais pas les femmes ne
sais pas si j'ai vécu ça mais chez la
coiffeuse en général c'est le résultat
le résultat qui enlève tout ça donc
lui son travail était sur le confort du
client et il avait une clientèle de
choix
même si la coiffure n'était pas une
trajectoire
centrale pour moi c'était quelque chose
que je faisais et la manière dont il le
faisait m'intéressait je suis la vue sur
l'émission je suis parti le lendemain
elle demande un stage il a accepté il ya
fait un stage deux mois et demi chez lui
demander de l'aide sur le chemin vous
allez vous sentir inadéquat perdu vous
allez vous demander en fait si vous
n'êtes pas en train de vous leurrer ça
m'est arrivé j'avais 24 ans et pendant
des années et j'avais répété à tout le
monde que j'étais créatrice de lutte et
c'était là où je voulais aller mais tous
les moyens n'étaient pas disponibles
et à au moins en fait j'avais commencé à
douter est ce que je n'étais pas en
train de me raconter des histoires est
ce que une fois mise devant toutes ces
choses que je voulais avoir je n'allais
pas me perdre
je me suis dis qu'il faut encore utilisé
la méthode de l'inspiration de la
demande est allé voir des personnes qui
l'ont déjà fait avant moi
il ya un entrepreneur dans la
communication au bénin qui a d'abord
fait ses études en médecine
et son histoire m'a touché
j'avais eu l'occasion de le rencontrer
chez encore demandé rendez vous j'ai
besoin d'une heure de votre temps je
veux savoir si je ne me permet pas
je me suis assise et sans filtre j'ai
posé toutes les questions que j'avais
sur le coeur
après cette heure je me suis senti mieux
aurait qu'un quai jusqu'à la prochaine
une certitude
donc nous nous sommes cherchés nous nous
sommes inspirés
l'étape qui suit nous allons apprendre
à prendre c'est rentrer dans le vif du
sujet
c'est ce n'est plus c'est spirées vague
manque du travail de psy de de ça mais
amenés dans le vif du sujet elle est du
côté technique de ce qu'on veut faire
certains vont me dire moi je vais être
un chef d'entreprise se met en place qui
vont le faire et où pourtant il vaut
mieux et je vous conseille de maîtriser
votre sujet dans une certaine mesure
avant d'embaucher des gens pour le faire
pour vous ça va vous épargner
énormément de soucis surtout si vous
allez installer votre entreprise au
bénin donc à l'étape de l'apprentissage
vous devez vous former en fait c'est
l'objectif et il arrive des moments
comme pour moi où
la formation est trop cher
je ne pouvais pas payer une école de
mode en france
c'était hors de prix alors il me fallait
déjà je devais commencer à travailler
même si je n'avais pas encore toutes les
compétences nécessaires
j'ai commencé à sous traiter à les voir
des personnes des maîtres d'eux qu'ils
allaient travailler avec moi mais
pendant ce temps j'observais japonais
donc ces périodes là m'ont aidé à en
venir aujourd'hui où j'en suis
nous nous sommes cherchés nous nous
sommes inspirés nous avons appris nous
allons nous lancer c'est une étape très
intéressante le lancement
on n'est jamais totalement prêts si vous
avez les moyens de vous lancer
à la mesure en fait de vos ambitions
c'est très bien il faut le faire si vous
ne les avez pas il faut le faire
je me suis lancé je vais dire à
plusieurs étapes je vous avais parlé de
coiffure premièrement la coiffure était
revenu dans ma vie à un moment où je
n'avais pas de machines à coudre donc je
ne pouvais pas coudre et moi même mais
il fallait qu'elle fasse quelque chose
donc j'ai commencé à coiffer par ce que
avec on va dire un budget de 5000 francs
1 on peut commencer un business de
coiffure peut-être -
et bien sûr
avoir avoir être passé par toutes les
étapes dont je parle c'est à dire savoir
ce qu'on va faire il faut pas juste
avoir c'est mille fois et acheter un
peigne et pu partir coiffé du coup ma
chère commencée la coiffure
et un moment il ya un style de coiffure
qui n est qu on appelle les crochets
britz et à cotonou ce on va dire que les
techniques qui apparaissent ailleurs
sont très en retard pour apparaître ici
du coup je crois que j'avais bon bâtir
deux ans d'avancé quand même est l'outil
principal qui servait à le faire
n'existait pas au bénin j'ai fait le
tour du marché dantokpa avec mon
téléphone et une photo de l'outil qui
coûtait 1 dollars aux états unis et tout
les à la dia se sont passées - téléphone
et personne n'avait le crochet je suis
rentré à la maison et j'étais décidé à
faire décrocher waits
d'examiner ce qu'il y avait autour et
j'ai trouvé une barrette une barrette ça
doit coûter en fait on n'en voit pas
l'unité si on en vendait à l'unité ça
coûterait peut-être qu est franc ou mais
c'est faux j'ai testé avec une barrette
ça a fonctionné et j'ai commencé à me
faire on va dire par coiffure 2000
francs avec une barrette de 15 francs
[Applaudissements]
alors il a fallu se lancer dans la
couture proprement dit ma machine celle
que j'avais gagné à un concours plutôt
avec laquelle je m'entraînais elle était
devenue défectueuse elle ne tenait plus
la route
j'avais une amie
d'enfance qui est
devenu par la suite maîtresse couturière
elle possédait une machine donc elle a
accepté de collaborer avec moi pour
réaliser mes idées on s'est installé
chez moi à la maison
je crois qu'on était sur la terrasse on
a essayé de se trouver un petit coin là
pour nous et inclut cris d'enfants on
travaille et
ça nous a pris deux ans c'était pas la
période la plus confortable mais on
sortait un travail magnifique et surtout
on a énormément appris de cette période
[Applaudissements]
alors nous sommes cherchés nous nous
sommes inspirés nous avons appris nous
sommes lancés il ya une étape
qui va assurément arrivés et qu'ils me
qui peut même arriver au milieu des
autres étapes c'est l'échec il faut être
prêt a échoué et vous allez échoué en
fait
on va vous dire le nom on va vous
ignorez on va vous laisser des vues je
ne sais plus le nombre de styles et sur
lequel j'écris sur internet
on va en fait vous allez recevoir
énormément de choses en pleine figure il
y aura un moment où vous allez vous dire
je suis proche du but est
non vous étiez papouasie du but ça va
arriver l'échec
comporte autant de leçons
sinon plus de leçons que la réussite est
en général on échoue plus quant à eux
réussi seulement qu'on ne montre
essentiellement que nos réussites
l'échec muscles
l'échec peut vous abattre mais il faut
simplement ne pas le laisser vous pigez
trop longtemps
de 2010 à 2015
j'avais l'espoir d'aller étudier la mode
en france
parce que les meilleures écoles y était
et il y avait des concours qui pouvait
me permettre de le faire chaque année je
concentraient
toute mon énergie pour
aller faire mes études de mode enfance
pour passer ces concours là et espérer
gagner et aller faire mes études en
france et à chaque fois
après le stress de
est ce que je vais recevoir la lettre ou
pas la lettre à chaque fois je recevais
la lettre nous sommes au regret de vous
annoncer que votre candidature n'a pas
été retenue cette fois-ci essayé l'année
prochaine gérer c'est jusqu'à athènes
l'attelage limites et ce n'est jamais
arrivé
ça m'a aidé
peut-être être plus résistante
également à comprendre que ce n'était
pas ma voix a écarté cette option
[Applaudissements]
il ya une autre manière dont j'ai échoué
qui était intéressante aussi
c'était également concours chez même
bien les concours ce concours devait me
permettre d'obtenir une master class est
également les fonds pour un félin c'est
mon business
ce concours avait été organisé au bénin
et je ne sais pas vous dire la chute de
cette histoire j'ai fait toutes les
étapes du congo avec d'autres personnes
que je connaissais mais arrivé à un
niveau
le concours a disparu je l'ait pas au
change je n'ai pas retrouvé à la soirée
où on devait annoncer qui a gagné je
vous dis pas ma robe de ce jour là à la
soirée j'y arrive et puis la soirée
s'est terminée sans convention et le
concours voilà
ça ça m'a plongé en fait d'un une sorte
de déprime s'était pas seulement le
concours mais c'était toutes ces années
là de préparation et le fait de se dire
je suis à nouveau à zéro
et c'est là qu'il faut vous avertir sur
la 6e étape être prêt à recommencer
il faut être prêt à recommencer
parce qu'en vérité tout ça c'est un test
il n'y a pas de certitudes vous
expérimentez ça fonctionne pas vous
recommencez parfois vous allez
recommencer le même projet mais
différemment et parfois vous allez
simplement arrêté et changer de
trajectoire soyez fluide et soyez prêt à
recommencer nous en venons à la 7e étape
la 7e étape s'est
c'est une étape qui également devrait
vous servir du début à la fin du
cheminement que j'explique c'est ce
challenge et c'est ce que je fais
aujourd'hui
ce challenge et venir devant on va dire
l'exemple d'aujourd'hui de nombreuses
personnes pour raconter votre histoire
prendre le risque de peut-être vous
planter c'est quelque chose qui muscle
en fait
votre capacité on va dire à vous
affirmez votre capacité à vous de
déséquilibrer en parlant de déséquilibre
aujourd'hui je tiens bien sûr des
chaussures à talons ça n'a pas toujours
été le cas
je me suis inscrite à une élection miss
d'envergure nationale deux fois de suite
et rassurez vous c'est épatant de
comparer à d'autres femmes ou pour
jauger ma beauté etc
l'objectif était
comme je l'aï dit tout à l'heure de 2 me
déséquilibre et de deux quand vous
n'êtes pas dans un parcours ce on va
dire académique ou ou de formation
classique des devoirs vous voulez donnez
vous même donc j'y suis allé
je suis pas tombé dans la piscine mais
peu s'en fallait
donc les deux années de suite vrai dire
on va dire que c'est un échec mais pour
moi pas vraiment quand vous challenge et
vous avez des objectifs personnels qui
sont différents des objectifs
de la foule en bâtir dont vous sortez
toujours gagnant d'une certaine manière
et vous réessayer il y à un autre salle
f dont je vais vous parler
c'est un challenge de couture en ce
moment disons que je savais qu outre
mais il y avait une certaine machine
qu'aujourd'hui j'ai terrasse et qui me
faisait peur si tu es une machine
vraiment très puissante et ce concours
là c'est ce qu'on avait cessé la machine
qu'on avait pour travail et on avait
deux heures de temps pour terminer une
robe je me battais avec cette machine
et il y avait le public les gens
pouvaient venir nous poser des questions
et tout ça et je me suis pas dégonflé
j'ai presque fini ma robe et la manche
il a juste fallu l'agrafé en fait pour
passer sur le pour passer sur le thé
mais j'étais j'étais fier de moi en fait
parce que la robe était belle mais en
plus de ça
j'avais commencé à dompter quelque chose
qui me faisait peur
je n'y étais pas totalement arriver mais
je me suis assise et j'ai essayé
d'utiliser cette machine et ça donnait
des coutures horrible mais une belle
tenue
et donc j'étais deuxième du concours
nous étions deux avec une collègue et
elle a gagné
mais
merci
sur le podium j'avais exactement le même
sourire en fait je crois qu'elle
pleurait que je riais
peut-être qu'elle pleurait de joie et
moi je rien parce que j'avais accompli
mon challenge personnel
n'arrêtez pas de voûte challenge et n'ai
pas peur de vous perdre trouver des
opportunités
de
deux vous déséquilibré le conseil que je
peux vous donner c'est
osé parce que en fait intégré de
l'audace dans sa vie c'est beaucoup plus
gratifiant que de
de vivre dans sa zone de confort
je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]